teasing now god
i'm trying to get the taste
[Music]
how can i help you
yeah
doing good how can i help you right here
okay what can i do for you
are you okay
okay what can i do for you man i just
wanted to chat i put my thumb out you
didn't respond oh man i can't stop in
the middle of traffic i pulled over i
mean i'm here or not i mean it's not
really traffic
okay well i can't park in the middle of
street i mean it's not necessary
what can i do for you i deal with you my
man i'm sorry i don't need anything okay
what you doing out here my friend
walking okay was that you to move the
cones over there
you sure but i was told you did but you
have a seat over here let's talk man
i've got mine let's have a seat
i need to see some id sir
come here come here come here turn
around turn around don't do that turn
turn around do not do this
do not do this turn around
you turn around you turn the fuck around
you don't want to do this though turn
around
turn
around stop resisting you don't want to
do this
can't give me another unit
brentwood north mckinley stop stop
stop fighting
just let me go
i'm trying to get the taser
[Music]
oh
bro
[Music]
i'm
here here here
you're about to die
let me go
big old boy
stop
why are you all hurting me
are you all hearing me toad
stop
stop hurting me stop help me stop
stop help me stop we are trying to help
you
stop
me
stop sir help me i didn't do anything
wrong josh get on the radio
we got it on the way
all right
go ahead
come on uh
[Applause]